dans l'actualité de ce jeudi 5 mai des
élus du plateau de saclay ont envoyé une
lettre au premier ministre
ils craignent que la future ligne 18 du
métro grand paris qui devrait relier
versailles à orly menace les terres
agricoles un grand gala de charité au
profit de l'ukraine est organisée ce
dimanche 8 mai au château barthélemy
dans la ville de paris nous aviez située
au sud des yvelines au programme un
concert de musique ainsi qu'un buffet
avec des plats traditionnels d'ukraine
les fonds récoltés seront reversés à des
associations pour envoyer du matériel
médical aux ukrainiens et de mardi à
mercredi la tension est montée entre des
policiers et des jeunes dans le quartier
du val-fourré à mantes-la-jolie
plusieurs incendiant était déclarée
entre 1h et 4h du matin à l'origine
l'interpellation d'un homme de 19 ans
qui était activement recherché par la
police en prenant la fuite il s'est
réfugié à l'insu d'une famille qui
fêtait l'aïd lors de l'intervention les
agents ont utilisé du gaz lacrymogène la
scène a été filmée et fait polémique la
mairie a mobilisé des médiateurs pour
apaiser la situation des agents
forestiers victimes d'agressions et
d'actes d'incivilité certains promeneurs
en colère à cause des opérations de
coupe d'arbres s'en prennent aux
employés de l'office national des forêts
dégradations de matériel menaces
insultes selon une enquête réalisée par
l'eau nf en ile-de-france 91% des agents
déclare avoir été victime ou témoin
d'une altercation on termine avec un peu
de sport un tournoi international de
tennis de table handisport a débuté ce
jeudi 5 mai au vélodrome nationale où
depuis le retour des jeux ils ont ils
ont coupé un petit peu et depuis janvier
on est un stage par mois pour le groupe
france donc à 18 sportifs à peu près et
donc là le dernier stage c'était ya deux
semaines donc on a peaufiné les derniers
réglages pour venir ici qu est l'une des
étapes importantes pour la qualification
aux championnats du monde qui seront à
me rendre le tournoi se poursuit
jusqu'au 8 mai en présence de 380
pongistes de l'élite internationale et
de plusieurs mais tazi paralympiques de
tokyo
[Musique]